نعم عبد السلام انا وانت غطينا حروب الكره
لنا التقينا في افغانستان وغطينا مناطق
نزاعات اخرى لكن حقيقه كتجربه شخصيه حجم
الدمار الذي رايته اليوم في مدينه انطاكيا
لم يسبق لي ان رايته في مسيره المهنيه
وتوقفنا في هذا المكان ليس بشكل اعتباطي
يعني بشكل اعتباطي في الحقيقه لانه المكان
الوحيد الذي سمح لنا بالتوقف فيه بعد جوله
طويله حاولنا التوقف خلالها للتجهيز لهذه
المقابله ما ارى امامي الان هذا المبنى
مدمر بشكل جزئي هذا المبنى مدمر بشكل كامل
امامي ثلاث جرافات تحاول رفع الانقاض من
ثلاث مباني مدمره بشكل كامل المبنى الذي
جنبها مدمر بشكل جزئي المبلغ الذي خلفها
مدمر بشكل كامل خلفي ايضا توجد جرافات
تحاول رفع الانقاض اعمال عمال الاغاثه
والمسعفين مستمره على مدار الساعه ويعملون
بنوبات هذه هذه النوبه تستريح لمده ساعه
او ساعتين ثم تاتي نوبه اخرى تحل محلها في
محاوله وسعي حديث لرفع الكم الهائل
والهائل والهائل من الانقاض من هذه
المباني المدمره كما ترى عبد السلام
المدينه حالكه الظلام جنبي بعض الضجيج لان
هناك محرك كهربائي يغذي الكهرباء لهذه
الجرافات التي يعني يحاول عمال ايقاد
هؤلاء رفع ما يمكن رفعه في محاوله للوصول
الى ناجين محتمل وهذا المشهد يتكرر في
جميع الشوارع في جميع الازقه في مدينه انط
الحقيقه المشهد مؤلم المشهد مرعب هذا
المشهد تعكسه ربما التصريحات الرسميه التي
تقول بان نصف المباني التي دمرها هذا
الزلزال في تركيا نصفها يوجد في ولايه
هاتاي وبالضبط في مدينه انطاكيا الحقيقه
ان يعني معاناه الناس ما تزال مستمره
خلال 24 الى 36 ساعه الماضيه هذه المعاناه
بدات تخف بشكل تدريجي بالنظر الى التدفق
الكبير للمساعدات وحاله ازدحام التي
تشهدها المدينه والتي بالمناسبه لا تتوقف
نحن نفسنا في هذه المدينه لمده خمس او ست
ساعات اقول لك عبد السلام باننا نسير
بسرعه كيلومترين الى خمس كيلومترات في
الساعه في الشوارع مختنقه بالنظر الى
التدفق الهائل للسيارات الاسعاف والشاحنات
التي تقل المساعدات الانسانيه والمواد
الاغاثيه التي جاءت من ولايات اخرى والتي
تم الارسال بها من المركز الى هذه المدينه
النائيه بدات هذه المساعده تتدفق صحيح ان
هناك من ان عمليه توزيعها تشوبها بعض
النواقص لانه لا يوجد هناك نظام او خيط
ناظم لتوزيع هذه المساعدات لكن على الاقل
هناك ارتياح لان عدد كبير من الخيام الان
يتم توزيعها على الاقل تقي الناس بروده
هذا الطقس القاسيه حقيقه يعني مع تزامن مع
هذه الازمه بدا الغذاء يتم توفيره بشكل
دوري منتظم من خلال خيام محدده وقف الناس
في طوابير من اجل الحصول على المواد
الاغاثيه وبالتالي هذه معاناه بدات تخف
لكنها معاناه ما تزال حقيقيه وما يزال
الخوف وسيد الموقف معظم الناس يعيشون في
الساحات العامه يعيشون في هذه الخيم التي
نصبها الحكومه التركيه في بعض المخيمات
ايضا التي اقامتها منظمات خيريه وهذا ايضا
يتزامل مع استمرار تدفق
المتطوعين وعمال الانقاذ الاجانب الذين
بداوا يصلون ايضا التقينا اليوم بولندي مع
وفود اجنبيه اخرى تحاول مساعده المسعفين
والمتطوعين المحليين اختم ربما بنغمه من
الامل وهو امر شاهدته اليوم صدفه وهو
اخراج طفل في السابعه من عمره مع احد
اقاربه بعد 84 ساعه من الزلزال يعني هذه
يعني كانت رساله امل لكل اهالي العالقين
الذين ربما بدا الياس يعني يستبد بهم من
احتمال يعني
العثور على اقاربهم احياء يبدو ان هناك
الامل لكن حقيقه انه امل يتضاءل وينقص مع
مرور الزمن عبد السلام